[Music]
on this sunday night
the vaccination push in canada
more shots on order but canadians are
still waiting
obviously it's not going as fast as
as everyone would want why is canada
still playing catch-up
compared to other countries foreign
policy and saudi arabia
is saudi arabia an ally of to canada
no how two allies are finding common
ground
on the kingdom the water crisis in first
nations communities
there's no consequences for that the
government isn't penalizing
accusations of shoddy infrastructure
projects
plus the serb and tax season it was not
free money what you need to know
to prepare your return
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us the prime minister is facing more
scrutiny over the country's vaccine
rollout today he appeared on a u.s
political talk show
where he once again insisted millions of
canadians will have the opportunity to
be inoculated
on friday health canada approved the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine
and it will boost canada's capacity to
immunize more people
that's once the shipments begin arriving
but that's little relief to people in
parts of this country facing
rising case numbers global's sean o'shea
reports
the push to vaccinate canadians against
covet 19
now includes those in one of the highest
risk populations in canada's largest
city
the homeless it's too late but i'm
really glad that it's actually happening
toronto will give 7 000 people who live
in shelters priority to receive vaccines
residents will begin getting their first
shots this week prioritizing this group
for vaccination
is is good public health and it's just
the right thing to do
cities across canada are mobilizing to
vaccinate as many residents as they can
in montreal this converted arena becomes
a full-time vaccination center on monday
the staff is geared up to give 1500
shots a day
it affects our employees our families
our
neighbors so it's it's very important to
us
85-year-old ronald yeoman is ready for
his turn to me
to get vaccinated is right
the problem across the country isn't a
lack of interest it's a shortage of
supply
only three and a half percent of
canadians have received at least one
dose of the vaccine
while in the united states more than
seven percent of the population is fully
vaccinated the government says it is
setting what it calls
realistic targets if we achieve our goal
of every canadian having access to
immunization to vaccination
earlier than the end of september that's
good news just approved last friday the
first half million doses of
astrazeneca's vaccine will arrive in
canada from india this week
johnson johnson's vaccine is still
awaiting the go-ahead from canadian
regulators it's nice to have good news
from time to time
but we must remember that our
precautions
both as individuals and our public
health interventions are really
important those ready to give out the
vaccines are upbeat we see hope
so we can't wait shawn o'shea global
news toronto
israel is the envy of much of the world
when it comes to its vaccination
campaign
more than half of all israeli citizens
have received at least
one dose the country has now rolled out
a vaccine certificate system which
allows those who have received both
shots
to go to gyms restaurants and cultural
events
but is it an idea that could catch on in
canada redmond shannon takes a look at
the benefits
and challenges
[Music]
remember live music it's no longer a
fond memory in israel partly down to its
super high speed covet 19 vaccine roll
out this is great because it's been a
long time that we didn't go out of the
house
no one is more pumped than benjamin
netanyahu
as the israeli prime minister campaigns
for yet another election
he shows off the green badge app
it will allow anyone who's had two
vaccine doses or who has
recovered from the virus to go to
non-essential venues like gyms and
cultural events
and possibly in the future to travel
internationally
there is a precedent some countries
require a yellow fever vaccine
certificate for entry
a similar system is possible for covert
travel according to the bioethicist
francoise bayless
we will have vaccine certificates it
would be irresponsible
of public health not to generate vaccine
certificates
the critical thing is what are they used
for
and how can the health data be securely
managed
obviously the downside of this is
privacy
and patient confidentiality and so forth
and i think we're going to see this
tension play out
i think people you know may be more open
to this type of intrusion
than they have in the past because of
the impact of the pandemic
other issues include the differing
efficacies of vaccines
and how exactly covert 19 immunity is
defined
we're still missing information about
transmissibility we now have these new
variants and it's turning out that
certain vaccines are not as effective or
are
probably ineffective against certain
variants
quebec is considering vaccine passports
and prime minister justin trudeau
won't rule out supporting them across
canada
we'll continue to pay close attention to
the recommendations that
our experts make in terms of measures
like that there are concerns these
certificates could lead to a two-tiered
society
where businesses could turn away the
non-vaccinated
why should we assume that the private
sector should be in control of
any of this and i think that's actually
right now a very serious discussion and
debate
around the world bayless says in the
race to return to some semblance of
normalcy
we need to remember whose rights might
get left behind
redmond shannon global news london
facing mounting pressure to take a tough
stance against saudi arabia
u.s president joe biden says he will
make a major announcement tomorrow
at issue is the intelligence report
showing crown prince mohammed bin salman
approved the assassination of journalist
jamal khashoggi
today canada's prime minister called for
an international effort to stop
human rights abuses but as jennifer
johnson reports
the region is key for both nations
u.s president joe biden plans to break
his silence on saudi arabia
after an intelligence report found the
crown prince and next in line to be king
signed off on the murder of journalist
jamal khashoggi
there'll be announcements on monday what
we're going to be doing
with saudi arabia khashoggi was last
seen alive entering the
saudi consulate in istanbul turkey where
he was killed and dismembered
according to u.s and u.n investigators
congress passed a law in 2019 demanding
president donald trump release the c.i.a
report
but trump who's had a close relationship
with the kingdom refused
now some lawmakers want the man on top
punished it's a day of reckoning but one
that is long overdue
prime minister justin trudeau said
sunday canada has consistently condemned
human rights abuses in saudi
arabia canada froze all new arms sales
to the kingdom shortly after khashoggi's
murder but the ban was lifted last year
is saudi arabia an ally of to canada
um no i wouldn't i wouldn't say it
they're they're a country we do business
with they're a country that we
continually advocate for uh greater
transparency greater human rights
uh protection the crown prince has
denied any involvement in khashoggi's
death
but the kingdom did prosecute some of
the hitmen many human rights groups say
it's now time for bin salman to pay
the crown prince needs to face
accountability he needs to face
sanctions
asset freezes travel bans and to let him
go
unpunished would be unconscionable but
it's a delicate balance for president
biden who sees saudi arabia as a key
ally in a volatile region
while running for president biden said
he would take a hard line against saudi
leaders
we were going to in fact make them pay
the price and
make them in fact the pariah that they
are for now the white house will only
say it's recalibrating its relationship
with saudi arabia
while calls are growing louder
especially among democrats
for president biden to hold the crown
prince accountable for the horrific
crime
jennifer johnson global news washington
in his first public appearance since
losing office donald trump spoke at the
conservative political action conference
in orlando florida
the largest annual gathering of
republicans and supporters
trump made it clear he will remain the
dominant force
within the republican party there's
never been a journey so
successful we began it together four
years ago
and it is far from being over
we're not starting new parties let there
be no doubt
we will be victorious and america will
be stronger
and greater than ever before
[Applause]
trump has been holding court in florida
since leaving the white house
and is positioning himself to play a
major role in the 2022
midterm elections now to the water
crisis
impacting first nations in canada an
organization
representing 34 first nations in
manitoba
is calling for an inquiry into how the
federal government reviews major
infrastructure projects a joint
investigation that includes global news
has been examining how outdated policies
have forced many first nations
to cope on their own krista hesse
reports
the southern chiefs organization says
federal officials
often force first nations to work with
substandard firms in order to save money
especially on key water projects now the
group representing anishinaabe and
dakota first nations in manitoba
wants an inquiry they're getting away
with this because
when they screw up on their their
projects
uh there's no consequences for that the
government
isn't penalizing this comes after a
joint investigation by global news
aptn news and the institute for
investigative journalism
it found a number of examples of first
nations who said the government forced
them to select the lowest bidding
contractor for their water projects
as a result many said they were forced
to deal with shoddy work
delays cost overruns and racism
it sure isn't in the interest of the
taxpayer it's not in the interest of the
first nation
and if it's going to continue then you
know uh
just be prepared to to realize that
we're going to be wasting money here
the chiefs also say that navigating
through federal bureaucracy can be
a nightmare the fact is that until first
nations are in control of their own
futures
as it relates to planning around water
and just infrastructure overall whether
it's housing
school systems recreational facilities
you're not going to get a return on
investment that you should all
infrastructure
the southern chiefs organization
proposed its own regional water
authority
but says federal officials have not
offered them much support
we don't even have the funding in the
bank yet we have on paper
we are committed to working with you
that's what we have but there are
project plans
indigenous services minister mark miller
disputes evidence and testimony
uncovered by global news and its
partners
about the harm caused by the
department's low bid policy
there is a value for money proposition
in any procurement process that follows
best industry practices but this isn't
about going with the cheap option
it's going with the option that suits
the first nation at the same time the
minister admits federal
policies are rooted in racism and need
to be changed
but he doesn't know how long this will
take christa hesse
global news after a week that saw the
newly installed chief of the defense
staff admiral art mcdonald's step aside
while military police investigate
allegations of misconduct
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stephenson sat down with major
kelly brennan for a follow-up interview
after she
sounded the alarm about the barriers
complainants of sexual misconduct
face in canada's military kelly
some people are wondering whether the
military can solve this
internally do you think that's possible
i don't i don't think it i don't think
that
the military can solve this problem it's
not a military problem
it's a personnel problem
in that i mean that this exists in
society this does
exists in other businesses but it's just
more pronounced in the military
because we live amongst each other
because we of the close
contact we have because one of our
founding uh re has all died for
for for officers is know your know your
soldiers
so you know everything about them i
think that maybe
we're just too close to solve it
ourselves
and that we have to take that that
step back and and let somebody else take
over
and create that lasting change
major brennan also told mercedes that
she wants canadians to believe in the
military
and she is confident that the canadian
armed forces will be able to overcome
this dark chapter canada's embassy in
yangon is condemning the violence in
myanmar calling it appalling
that country witnessed its bloodiest day
since the military coup sparked
nationwide demonstrations
in the latest crackdown on protesters
security forces killed at least 18
people
dozens more were wounded a u.n human
rights representative on the ground says
the protests had been peaceful
until the police moved in throughout the
weekend there have been mass arrests
across myanmar
protesters are demanding the elected
government of aung san tsuchi
be restored to power coming up the rise
in booze sales
and increasing health concerns
dry february is coming to an end tonight
the canadian cancer society's campaign
asks people to stop drinking for a month
to reduce the risk of cancer
but the pandemic has spiked levels of
anxiety depression
and loneliness so more canadians are
turning to alcohol as a coping mechanism
as caitlyn wilson reports that's boosted
the business
of booze
when the pandemic first hit we were
quite worried just as everybody else was
with alcohol deemed an essential service
financial worries quickly eased for
saskatchewan liquor store owner
phillip mccallery as sales started to
soar
it was dramatic
within the first couple of months
mckellery says sales
shot up 40 percent and deliveries
increased
threefold since then he says both have
remained steady
it wasn't a shock because people are
stuck at home not
not being able to do anything according
to the canadian center on substance use
and addiction
since the pandemic began 25 percent of
canadians between 35
and 54 say they're drinking more
pointing to factors such as stress
boredom and lack of a regular schedule
we're certainly seeing increases in the
number of people requiring admission
for alcohol withdrawal and these are
people coming from across the social
economic spectrum
mental health and addictions expert
peter butt says
increased access to alcohol combined
with social isolation and anxiety
is leading to unintended consequences
people that
were perhaps episodic drinkers have
become daily drinkers if
every day as a friday or saturday and
then it gets to a level
where it can shift to the point that
they're drinking to avoid withdrawal
and you don't have to look far to see
how accessible
alcohol has become in alberta willow
park wine and spirits says
when the pandemic hit it shifted
primarily to e-commerce and delivery
we went from having five deliveries a
day in alberta to 200.
but experts worry the hangover from the
alcohol boom
could linger long after the pandemic has
ended
caitlin wilson global news regina
still ahead after a year of the
pandemic's financial woes are you ready
for tax season
nearly 9 million canadians received
covet 19 relief benefits last year
including the serb that all has to be
calculated on tax returns
plus there are new tax benefits for
people who are forced to work from home
as michael couture reports this tax
season
is a complicated one 15 and 16 months
dennis amyot hasn't filed his taxes in
five
years complicating things he drew on the
kennedy emergency response benefit in
2020
and he's trying to recoup years of
unclaimed federal child benefits
it was it was a little bit overwhelming
sometimes
between my girls for my girl's sake they
were they're they're on my case to get
it done
that's why he decided to get help at
this free community tax clinic but even
the pros admit
this year won't be easy this is one of
the most confusing seasons i've been a
part of
lisa giddings of h r block says the
different benefits claimed by canadians
will make it more complicated
especially since the cerb wasn't taxed
at the source but other government
programs like
the canada recovery benefit were that's
why she suggests people remember
one rule with all of these benefits any
federal benefits received expect
to have some tax owing on your return
it was not free money the government is
allowing you to claim
two dollars for each day the pandemic
that you had to work from home
up to 400 or you can claim
other expenses like your phone and
internet bill
sarah jane martin has worked from home
for years and says
you need to keep all of your receipts
i'm not a numbers person so just having
one color
for monthly expenses and then another
just for one-offs that pop up every once
in a while
if you have any questions you can always
call the canada revenue agency which
has seen a surge in calls we've seen an
83 percent increase in call volume the
parliamentary secretary to the revenue
minister says a third party company
is helping to answer some of those basic
questions
while they hire 2 000 more agents and to
relieve
some of the stress cra has an interest
relief program
if you owe money to the canada revenue
agency because you've collected certain
benefit programs
that there'll be no penalties no
interest on those funds that you owe
until april of 2022 that only applies if
you've collected from a benefit program
but if you didn't and still owe money
that's due april 30th of this year
mike lacouter global news ottawa
up next the distracted doctor bouncing
between the courtroom
and the operating room so can everybody
hear me
are you available for trial it kind of
looks like you're in an operating room
right now
i am sir i'm in operating room yes i'm
available for trial go right ahead
a plastic surgeon in california insisted
on attending a virtual court hearing to
fight a traffic ticket
while operating on a patient this video
captured by the sacramento bee shows dr
scott green
performing surgery while waiting for the
judge but the judge
was not amused so
unless i'm mistaken i'm seeing a
defendant that's in the middle of an
operating room appearing to be actively
engaged in
providing services to a patient is that
correct mr green
yes sir or what i should i say dr greene
the judge didn't think it was
appropriate and postponed the trial
but now the medical board of california
is investigating
the incident and u.s vice president
kamala harris has made a call
deep into space the history making that
you are doing we are
so proud of you it is great to talk to
you welcome to the international space
station
nasa just posted last week's virtual
chat between the vice president and
victor glover for black history month
glover is the first black crew member
living on the space station
the 44 year old arrived in november and
just completed his third spacewalk
today glover and fellow astronaut kate
rubins worked
over seven hours on upgrades to the
lab's
solar power system and from the darkness
of outer space
we leave you tonight with some down to
earth inspiration
for your next snowfort
eleven-year-old sebastian mccarthy from
lloydminster alberta spent
two months completing this impressive
build at times he braved temperatures
that dipped to minus 53.
thanks for watching good night
[Music]
you